défi
communiste communisants
vérité
d'hommes semblables houngbo
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous écoutez
ce coupé ou l'observatoire politique je
suis lucas da silva cofondateur de
scopeo et je vous souhaite aujourd'hui
la bienvenue sur ce douzième épisode
déjà de notre série l'entrevue politique
aujourd'hui nous sommes très heureux de
recevoir un jeune journaliste en
formation qui aura l'occasion de se
présenter en quelques mots plus tard
monsieur pierre valentin qui a récemment
gagné en notoriété grâce à la
publication de son étude en deux volumes
sur l'idéologie works sur le site un de
fondapol ou fondations privations
politique avant tout avant de rentrer
dans le vif du sujet je laisse la parole
à lucas paria également en europe membre
de scopeo pour qu'ils puissent poser le
décor de ce nouveau podcast
merci lucas bonjour à celle des à ceux
qui nous écoutent et surtout bonjour à
vous monsieur pierre valentin bonjour
vous le faites le plaisir aujourd'hui de
nous accorder cette entrevue pour
discuter ensemble de l'un des termes
qu'on retrouve de plus en plus
fréquemment dans la bouche de la classe
politico médiatique le hoki sme où
l'idéologie moque est ce un phénomène
concret qui s'ancre dans la réalité ou
est ce simplement une chimère qui sert à
disqualifier ses opposants politiques
c'est ce que deux chercheront à
comprendre avec vous mais avant de
démarrer l'entrevue monsieur valentin je
voulais vous présenter brièvement pour
ceux qui nous écoutent
alors du coup moi déjà merci pour votre
habitation j'ai
étudié notamment avec ses terres au
royaume uni ou gérer ces questions là
n'était déjà des sujets avant de devenir
un sujet en france il est un peu
d'avancé qu'ils ont toutes ces questions
et il ya actuellement je suis étudiant
en sciences politiques en master et
donc j'ai écrit pour la fondation pour
l'innovation politique mme hakima
commandé cette note en deux volumes sur
la question du gaullisme
dis-moi m'intéresse c'est là mon sens
c'est vraiment des gros sujets
dans les prochaines années et qui
d'ailleurs est déjà en train de prendre
de l'ampleur par rapport à juillet
dernier au moment de la publication de
la note
donc vous avez vous avez et à son hôte
reconnu de plein fouet le phénomène dans
vos universités les lycées dans lesquels
vous avez eu l'occasion d'étudier
justement la première chose je pense
pour poser les bases solides de notre
discussion est-ce que vous pouvez nous
apporter une définition claire précise
du oxm d'où il vient le terme
et que signifie t'il selon vous
précisément bien sûr alors il ya il ya
plusieurs choses à dire
une première c'est qu'on peut définir
les outils sont plusieurs façons faire
qu'il ya un angle sociologique qui en
angle picot logique un angle philosophie
est que
le phénomène que le mot qui décrit est
indiscutable et ensuite la manière de le
nommer lui est discutable
qu'est ce que c'est que ce phénomène
déjà il ya un clivage générationnel on
voit qu'il ya une jeune gauche qui ne
pensent pas pareil que d'une gauche de
plus de 35 ans ça c'est indiscutable il
ya un excellent papier d'art du figaro
sur la question écrit à quelques jours
sur le clivage générationnel au sein des
rédactions comme libération le monde ou
lopsi
accessoirement pas ça pour me victimise
et n'est rien mais c'est quasiment les
trois seuls médias papier qui n'ont pas
parlé de la note
donc clivage générationnel maintenant
aux rockies moi qui signifie être
réveillé ça signifie aussi être vigilent
dans ce qu initialement c'est
l'injonction positive le hashtag style
rock qui commence dans la communauté
afro américaine à gagner un peu en
popularité disons au début des années
2000 il ferme et 2000 ensuite début
d'année 2010 à se popularise vraiment
s'est repris notamment par blake lively
matters il ya un documentaire de
blacklight matters fait avec certains de
ses membres en 2016 qui s'intitule high
stakes de plaques l'animateur movement
on voit aussi en 2016 jack dorsey qui
arbore fièrement un t-shirt steua le
hashtag donc c'est un termine évidemment
positif c'est une revendication positif
quand on nous dit aujourd'hui personne
ne s'en réclament c'est vrai en fait à
ce stade mais c'est historiquement faut
des gens sont calmes et le terme est
initialement positif c'est comme ça que
ce qui est politiquement ensuite
voilà on ceux qui prônent
l'intersexualité on prend peut-être
reparler ceux qui voient la société
comme étant hétéro patriarcale on peut
les nommer comme on veut il se trouve
que c'est un phénomène qui existe et qui
est générationnel mans
constitué qui
statuent chironomes des rues qui virent
des professeurs qui les menaces de mort
dans certains cas tout ça ça existe une
réalité qui existe maintenant on se pose
la question de comment les nommer comme
j'ai dit je t'ai renouveau que j'y tiens
mais pas non plus je suis pas prêt à en
mourir moi ce que je veux pas qu'on
fasse par contre c'est qu'on nous fasse
croire qu'il n'y a pas de clivage au
sein de la gauche qu'on parle juste de
progressisme au sens large alors que
justement ça ne distingue pas entre un
progressisme si vous voulez justement
qui déplore la pertinence des catégories
raciales et sexuelles dans le domaine
politique qui dit on ne devrait pas
accorder une telle pertinence à ces
termes c'est ce qu'a fait notamment
martin luther king et le wac hills mais
qui fait l'inversé qui dit il faut
arrêter d'être color blind il faut
arrêter de me faire croire que la race
n'est pas un enjeu eux n'est pas disons
une grille de lecture fondamentale et
primaire première dans notre société
aujourd'hui donc voilà pourquoi moi je
tiens à ce terme est pour pour parler du
terme plus précisément et pas juste de
la réalité à laquelle ils renvoient moi
ce que j'aime bien avec le morro c'est
quand même cette idée qu'il ya quelques
petites personnes petite minorité
éveillé ou qu vigilante qui perçoit les
dominations là où
le reste de la société endormi on est
face à des masses endormi qui ne se
rendent pas compte que dans la manière
dont la boulangère m'a rendu mes armes à
monnet il y avait un réflexe encore
colonialiste que dans la manière dont
mon père m'a serré la main il ya le
patriarcat qui s'incarne et là dans la
manière dont le blanc conduit sa voiture
il ya encore un phénomène raciste le
commun des mortels ne voit pas ça mais
le walk qui a accès à une éducation
supérieure qui a accès à une révélation
supérieur lui perçoit mal donc il est
éveillé pendant 30 ans
voilà si vous voulez comme un propos
introductif voilà ce que j'aimerais
alors merci vous avez des queues en fin
de cette réponse d'évoquer des
comportements qui paraissent assez
quotidien comme rendre la monnaie ou
encore une certaine façon qui
témoignerait d'un comportement par
exemple colonialiste devrait faire le
lien avec ce que vous expliquez dans une
partie de votre lecture dans une partie
de votre étude pardon comme quoi le
nautisme accentuerait les troubles
psychologiques et entraînerait une auto
alimentation des processus de distorsion
de la réalité
qui donc
se témoignerait en la conscience de
micro agression avec
la sueur présence on va dire de trigger
warning ce plongeon finalement plus
profond des troubles on devrait alors la
sortie du mouvement au cas difficile
psychologiquement pour les jeunes et
témoignerait alors peut-être une forme
d' emprise psychologique du mouvement en
ajoutant à cela toute la dimension
complotistes l'intolérance à
l'opposition aux opinions divergentes on
peut se demander si une telle idéologie
est compatible avec les valeurs
défendues par la république française je
voudrais vous demander concrètement est
ce qu'on doit lutter politiquement quand
il est au logis works est ce que les
deux régimes rock est un danger
plusieurs choses dans votre question
déjà philosophiquement
un mouvement intellectuel croit ni à
l'universel nyon la rationalité et ni
ans l'individu même si l'inde il
faudrait nuancer puisque y croit quand
même un ressenti individuelle qui est
sacralisé dans certains cas mais disons
pour faire simple individu
universel nationalité trois choses que
la république française le shérif trois
choses qu'elle le vaut qu'ils ne croient
pas de ce point de vue là il ya
clairement une incompatibilité c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui se traduit dans ce que
ce fameux clivage générationnel qui est
également un clivage philosophique
ensuite si vous avez parlé de l'aspect
psychologique
- dans la conviction ont travaillé sur
ces questions là c'est qu'on ne pouvait
pas traiter la philosophie boucle sans
parler de la psychologie de cette
génération et qu' il ya des parallèles
fascinant à tracer entre les deux mais
qu'il fallait faire une approche soulève
pluridisciplinaire où transitent hier
pour parler de ce film
prenons par exemple la théorie critique
de la race particulièrement populaire en
amérique
on en parle beaucoup c'est vraiment un
grand sujet de clivage observé est
arrivé je pense dans quelques mois en
france
vraisemblablement elle a deux et
compliqué simple par certains aspects
mais ils ont quel à 2 prémisse si on
voulait schématiser la première c'est
que le racisme le pire péché qui existe
et la seconde c'est qu'il était
encastrée dans l'intégralité d'une
structure dont le nom de notre réalité
sociale cercle l'héritage c'est pour
reprendre là la phrase de pierre andré
taguieff qui pour le coup parle du des
colonialismes mais ça s'applique
également ici dans la mesure où
l'héritage de colonial serait partout
tuerait le politique artistique
l'impératif des colonials est ainsi
formule able to décoloniser pour tout
est construit beaucoup on a
simultanément l'idée que le racisme
lubie repêché et qu'il est partout et
donc de ce point de vue là on en conclut
très logiquement que toute la réalité en
fait très mauvaise que comme je disais
tout à l'heure la manière de serrer la
main la manière de parler tout tout est
infestée de racisme et que c'est
impossible d'y échapper robin di angelo
d'ailleurs très populaire chez reebok
ibrahim unix kenzy sont assez clairs là
dessus le racisme est partout et
rivalise ces penseurs de nouvelles
manières de trouver du racisme à tel
point que le conte satirique titanium
agrafes à faire un fils qui recense 144
choses qui ont déjà été décrit comme un
raciste ou alors comme un si bon un
système raciste ce qui dans leur
nouvelle définition du racisme et une
seule et même chose mais dans cette
liste on trouve le poisson changement
climatique que sage donc pourquoi je dis
ça parce que forcément lorsque vous avez
cette philosophie là ça va avoir un
impact sur votre psychologie vous allez
regarder le monde vous allez sans
mauvais jeu de mots noircir le monde
tout est mauvais et afin de me tenir en
fait à cette idée d'impuretés radicale
du monde vous allez obligé de fil très
négativement ce qu'une distorsions
cognitives le négatif surtout mentale
des psychologues que j'ai cités
notamment de dans mon rapport
c'est par exemple une personne déprimée
pratique les distorsions cognitives qui
pratique également
encourageant tout cas le hockey c'est
jeu côtoient des personnes je côtoie des
réalités parmi toutes les choses qui
vont arriver il y aura une chose faite
on propose un gars dit les cinq choses
positives et si je suis très
négativement en rentrant chez moi je
veux dire quelle journée de merde j'ai
trois choses négatives qui ce que des
choses positives je veux même plus les
voir gelée disqualifié dans ma tête donc
afin de rester mots qu'il faut pratiquer
ces distorsions que musique sinon vous
allez voir de source d'émerveillement
des sources de gratitude de toutes ces
choses là qui sont l'antithèse
fondamentales du comportement ou donc
pour moi il ya un lien clair entre les
deux est là où le lien est encore plus
évident il est à mon sens ce
chimiquement pur ces deux fonctions
chimiques nature c'est dans le cas des
dix abilities te disent les dix
stability stadistes donc les études de
lettres du handicap disent on va dire
que lorsqu'on cherche à éradiquer le
handicap en réalité est là il projette
le nazisme qui est leur seule référence
culturelle surtout on cherche en fait à
éradiquer les handicapés dont on dit
lutter et ciblée contre la surdité
contre
le fait d'être aveugle non non c'est en
fait éradiqué génocide et que sais-je
les sourds et les aveugles et pareil
dans la mesure où le statut de victime
devient un statut de marginal à mettre
en avant on va dire
ce que ceux qui cherchent en fait à se
guérir ou du moins 10 et si vous voulez
à minimiser la portée de ces handicaps
sur leur vie à devenir un peu moins
sourds à avoir qu'on leur fasse des
opérations et notamment des progrès de
la science magnifique sur la question eh
bien on va dire vous trahissez votre
camp vous rejoignez le camp des
dominants donc on va en cours on va
décourager violemment le fait d'aller
mieux si vous voulez dans l'idée que
toute science qui va vous dire qu'en
fait ces choses là forcément on
atteindre votre vie ça c'est purement
une construction sociale des dominants
afin de primer les marchés misent donc
la jonction est très clair là dessus et
on pourrait en parler des heures parce
que le sujet de la santé mentale et du
goût qui sont vraiment est fondamentale
et passionnante et on pourra pas acheter
les autisme sans étudier la question de
la santé mentale la psychologie du
rapport aux écrans au numérique
donc oui de ce point de vue là il ya
forcément des risques
sans eau santé publique dont l'autisme
alors je voudrais revenir une nouvelle
fois sur sur votre étude que deviendront
recommandons à quiconque pour plonger
pour prolonger le sujet pour prolonger
entrevue
vous l'expliquez vous avez d'ailleurs
mentionné un petit peu la théorie
critique de la race qui vient des états
unis
ce phénomène rock il vient d'abord et
avant tout des états unis c'est son
origine sociale son origine politique
d'origine géographique particulièrement
des universités américaines du monde
étudiant
moi je voudrais savoir est ce qu'il ya
les mêmes réalités et conséquences en
europe et en france
puisque si c'est d'abord implantée aux
états unis et s'il a d'abord des
conséquences aux états unis on peut se
demander si les réalités sociales sont
les mêmes en france et en europe je
pense d'ailleurs au gouvernement qui a
récemment montré une grande inquiétude
dans l'art ce phénomène à l'image de
jean-michel bancaire au niveau de
l'éducation nationale est ce que c'est
vraiment un danger de qui se retrouvent
dans la même intensité en france qu'aux
états unis
non pas pour répondre à votre question
pas encore
disons que pour faire une métaphore en
amérique les questions beaucoup contre
nom au dos
c'est le clivage numéro dire que très
clairement
c'est vraiment le filage qui rythme la
vie politique au royaume uni c'est
devenu le clivage 93 selon le sondeur
frank l'omsc qui en juillet dernier
montré que c'était quand on pose la
question en fait à l'électorat anglais
les trois clivage est plus important les
citer aux dispenses raciale et lui
prédisait en juillet dernier est pour
l'instant sa prophétie est plutôt en
train de se réaliser que leur mini
suivrait l'exemple américain un exemple
entre guillemets dans les 6 à 12
prochains mois donc là on entre dans
cette phase là et on voit que par
exemple même boris johnson et qui
premier ministre conservateur en théorie
n'ose même pas se prononcer contre le
mouvement trans ou ce qu on les pose la
question
est ce que c'est vrai que seules les
femmes ont un col de l'utérus il ose pas
dire oui il n'ya pas à dire de plus
leucate en fait par peur de foncer cette
nouvelle idéologie et nous on est si
vous voulez à la remorque des anglais
qui sont à la remorque les américains et
il semble qu'on est en train de se
diriger vers ça on voit qu'en france une
candidature comme son aîné rousseau très
ouvertement walkie qui se gargarisent de
vivre avec un homme déconstruit mais bon
ça c'était un peu impensable à quelques
années déjà moi je pense pas qu'on ait
les reins candidat ou en
2022 je pense que la france n'est pas
encore prête pour ça mais on voit moi
j'ai beaucoup de contacts avec des gens
du monde de l'entreprise qui disent
qu'ils voient cela arrive et on a vu
qu'en amérique par exemple y avait des
des séances de des blanches isation non
aider les employés j'en parlais dans le
second volume de la note à être moins
blanc donc à se détacher la solidarité
blanche etc ça s'est progressivement en
train d'arriver en france de ce que je
comprends il ya un clivage entre
filiales françaises d'entreprises
américaines ou encore
entreprises françaises multinationales
comme le real qui a décidé de retirer
tout ce qui était blanchi sans de ses
produits parce que c'était jugé
offensant
et un clivage par rapport aux
entreprises franco française
franchouillarde entre guillemets qui
elle forcément sur un peu moins atteinte
mais c'est en train de se propager j'ai
vraiment beaucoup de retours là dessus
très récemment gentil me dit ça
maintenant dans le monde universitaire
français
c'est clair que c'est vraiment très
dominant à la différence près mais je
suis habitué à débattre à force avec des
sociologues qui me dise circulez rien à
voir la différence près que si vous
voulez nos sociologues français
contrairement aux sociologues américains
soit un peu obligé de faire un
entre-deux veut dire qu'il vous dise pas
oui ce mouvement est génial ils vont
vous dire soit ça n'existe pas moi
j'aime bien faire cette blague le
poisson n'est pas un terme universitaire
donc le poisson n'existe pas c'est un
peu le rapport qu'ils ont acquise parce
qu'ils n'aiment pas le terme ils disent
que ça n'aurait aucune réalité c'était
vraiment de la folie pour le coup ou
alors ils vous disent on en fait trop
alors il faut un sophisme et qui ont si
c'est à dire à qui profite le crime en
disant ça sert tel ou tel intérêt
politique ce qui n'est pas une réponse
sur le fond sera d'accord là dessus mais
en tout cas qui peuvent pas dire ce truc
là et geignard is on s'est dit mais
c'est pas mal mais ça va un peu loin et
donc ils sont encore obligés de faire un
entre deux en amérique ils s'en fichent
de faire un entre deux ils vont à fond
les ballons les blancs sont tous les
blancs sont à six points d'art robin di
jodi sapin donc nous on est quand même
dans une phase intermédiaire on voit que
ça arrive ça progresse on voit que 13%
des français
adhèrent à l'écriture la cuisine sondage
réalisé en février dernier mois je pense
qu'entre temps ça a dû beaucoup augmenté
et la question aussi en fait c'est pas
en fait les gens parfois parce que en
politique ou alors on fait un grand
référendum pour ou contre l'autisme et
que évidemment le camp des mots que je
gagnerais largement ou parce que on le
voit dans les sondages même les thèmes
les plus populaires est encore à 80 %
des français qui trouvent ça affreux
mais en fait ce n'est pas la question la
question c'est que pensent nos élites de
demain et là qu'on se penche sur les
sondages on voit déjà que chez les 18-35
ans 41% des français avec la notion de
racisme historique
interventions des 18-35 ans si on
poursuit la courbe c'est quand même pas
la même france en quelques années et
plus généralement il ya un clivage
social les classes populaires évidemment
ce point n'ont même pas entendu parler
de ces termes soient quand ils entendent
parler disent non mais en fait on veut
pas de ça ne nous intéresse pas le
gothisme est un opium des intellectuels
pour paraphraser le moins rond mais le
problème c'est qu'en fait que les élites
de demain bon ben c'est les gens qui
vont rentrer dans le domaine
institutionnel c'est les jeunes diplômés
qui vont rentrer dans les médias qui
vont rentrer dans l'es2 le domaine afin
qu'ils vont devenir avocat et qui vont
faire des procès dans tous les sens
c'est des personnes qui vont être le
domaine artistique c'est ce qu'ils vont
créer des séries qu'on et flix donc ça
c'est fait c'est le monde de demain et
on voit bien je dirais par le passé que
les élites de demain ont tendance à
battre la cadence
culturellement donc de ce point de vue
là c'est un vrai sujet prend les paris
on va voir ce ce phénomène c'est déjà le
cas on aurait pu parler en juillet
dernier si je t'avais dit ça va être un
des grands sujets de la présidentielle
m'aurait peut-être dira franchement faut
pas exagérer de fait aujourd'hui c'est
un des sujets la présidentielle et donc
moi je pense que par exemple pour
revenir sur les questions inclusive en
2027 ça me paraît très probable que les
partis de gauche qui ne rédige pas leur
programme en écriture inclusif attrait
taxé de réactionnaire on voit que
yannick jadot le fait on voit que en
2017 il est que benoît hamon s'est dit
pas de bêtise il faudrait vérifier que
jean luc mélenchon mais je crois qu'il
est plus que benoît hamon aujourd'hui
mélenchon au soja dos ils font tout ça
en effectuant la cuisine et je pense
qu'en 2027 ce sera vraiment vu comme sur
deux bizarreries d'arrière-garde de ne
pas rédiger son programme intégralement
l'écriture l'inclusion donc oui on est
sur une dynamique exponentielle et est
on en train de suivre l'amérique mais
comme je lis tout à l'heure on a quand
même des républicains de gauche on
appelle une gauche ce qui nous distingue
on a une gauche qui n'est pas
entièrement rock il ya une gauche
nombreux qu on avait que politiquement
elle pèse plus rien alors qu'en france
on voit notamment avec des personnes de
la majorité présidentielle sont pas tous
de gauche mais qui quand même porte un
message anti au convoi marianne s'ils
voulaient sur une républicaine voix
l'express aussi x on line de centre
gauche progressiste qui sont contre le
bouddhisme ça c'est pas le cas à la fin
ça n'existe plus vraiment un niveau si
vous voulez populaire politique
institutionnelle en maîtres de ce point
de vue-là roses des sables les
américains mais ma question c'est pour
pour combien de temps surtout dans la
mesure où le clivage au sein de cette
gauche essentiellement générationnelle
fonctions poursuit si la courbe en
quelques années et puis toutes les la
fréquence d'utilisation des terres mot
qui est vraiment comme ça c'est la
verticale donc se poursuivre à
courbevoie donc voilà pourquoi moi je
pense que c'est vraiment on est en train
de suivre le schéma américain maintenant
c'est pas couru d'avancé on verra
alors on l'a vu il ya quelques minutes
l'antiracisme est une des
caractéristiques initiales du mouvement
walk central du mouvement rock
je me demandais et tyloo est il devenu
un nouveau racisme envers ceux qui sont
considérés comme privilégiés vous avez
tout à l'heure on peut entendre des
déclarations aux états unis comme tous
les blancs sont racistes dans une
dynamique semblable j'ajouterai est ce
que le néo féminisme pour vous est une
forme de nouveaux sexisme oui on sait
c'est au centre en fait du clivage entre
les deux gauches en france
et entre les deux gauches à la base en
amérique ce que l'une des deux a été
progressivement marginalisé pour ne plus
vraiment être très audible enfin sans
être traité de l'homme de droite
alors
moi je vous citais encore une fois le
compte titres satiriques titanium
agrafes dont je suis très fan ou non
courage toulouse auditeurs allaient voir
ça vous abonner d'avoir sa sueur sur les
réseaux sociaux
elle a écrit une tribune via un nom
maintenant que c'est en avril 2020 où
elle termine et magistralement en dix
ans
éduquons les masses renommant les rues
interdisant toutes les mauvaises
opinions brûlons les livres les mauvais
livres c'est la seule manière de vaincre
le fascisme
donc on comprend en fait dans ce propos
assez assez drôle qui a pour but
évidemment de faire rire réfléchir
également
que sous prétexte ou sortir d'un monde
affreux on va faire advenir dans mon
affreux serre que sous prétexte de
quitter le fascisme là on comprend bien
en disant brûlons les livres etc va
faire advenir un infléchissement
d'ailleurs lé prophète comme toujours
elle a d'ailleurs un fil des treize ou
quatorze entrait désormais où est le
nombre de fois où leur a prédit l'avenir
elle avait fait un tweet il ya assez
longtemps en dix ans le problème avec
les livres numériques c'est qu'on ne
peut pas les brûler s'ils sont
offensants et on a vu j'avais écrit un
article de supports notamment au canada
des autodafés inclusif où on fait brûler
des livres au nom du bien évidemment
donc
donc pour répondre à votre question je
sais un préambule sous couvert en fait
de sortir du racisme aurait institué la
même chose qu'on prétendait combattre on
restitue une logique de ségrégation avec
des espaces non mixtes notamment alors
que évidemment toutes les années 60 avec
le mouvement des droits civiques c'était
lutter contre la ségrégation
ont créé un institut en fait sauf qu'en
fait on cherche pas à l'égalité
parce que l'égalité ça veut dire la
neutralité la neutralité philosophique
mans procède n'existe pas c'est une
construction sociale des blancs
est donc dans la mesure où l'égalité
n'existe pas on va juste faire la
hiérarchie à l'envers
cc s'ils voulaient ils ont forcément
caricature et derrida mais des impôts ce
qui est des séries là où je le cite
notamment dans la première partie du
premier volume où il va dire voilà toute
opposition de concepts paroles écrits
par exemple n'est jamais une mise au
même niveau mais toujours une
subordination il n'y a pas d'égalité est
toujours une hiérarchie il n'ya que
domination domination c'est forcément
l'un au dessus de l'autre il est donc
dans la mesure où il n'y a que ça où il
n'y a que pouvoir il faut juste que le
pouvoir soit pour la bonne cause
jusqu'où on ne presse mais pour la bonne
cause il faut juste qu'on domine pour la
bonne cause et pour pour parler là aussi
donné au féminisme pouvoir avec alice
coffin par exemple elle elle prône pas
la légalité finalement elle prône la
dissolution des hommes elle dit mais je
ne veux plus voir d'hommes dans mais il
faut qu'on arrête d'acheter leurs livres
qu'on arrête de les voir également
pauline armange qui écrit un ouvrage au
titre assez éloquent mois les hommes je
les déteste et on comprend là ici
comment le terme de diversité paraît
enfin paré pour le terme de racisme a
changé de signification la diversité ce
n'est plus si vous voulez un pluralisme
c'est la dissolution la disparition des
dominants il ya houria bouteldja
notamment donc très présente dans le
mouvement indigéniste qui là aussi je le
cite un dans la première partie du
premier volume qui l'a dit hier nous en
s'arrogeant le droit de parler au nom de
tous les immigrés en france
créés en dix ans par
islamisant noir ils ont la france est
donc en fait l'objectif de ce point de
vue là c'est juste moins dominants c'est
pas une un peu râler c'est différent
parce que c'est un processus négatif
c'est pas un processus d' équilibre
c'est un processus de destruction donc
c'est vraiment très différent et pour
terminer bien sûr clivage entre anciens
d'antiracisme est nouvelle en tire ainsi
son antre progressisme
à l'ancienne entre guillemets même si ce
terme un peu un oxymore est ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui le cube autisme il ya
un manuel sur la théorie critique de la
race qui de manière assez franches qui
sont pas toujours franc parfois il ils
mentent par si on se rafraîchit
publicitaire de manière assez habile eu
un déclin élan d'honnêteté richard
delgado et john stéphane chic dans ce
manuel vont dire contrairement au
mouvement des droits civiques
traditionnelle qu'elle a déjà tout est
dit
la théorie critique de la race critiqué
les fondements mêmes de l'ordre libéral
y compris le rationalisme des lumières
l'égalité juridique j'ai pu tout la
liste mais ils font une longue liste on
explique en fait on n'est pas comme ces
gens là donc ce qui ensuite essaye de
dire là on est comme martin luther king
alors que précisément et juge sur la
couleur de peau et non pas sur le
contenu du caractère c'est évidemment
une tartufferie c'est une vaste blague
et et c'est ce que j'essaie de
comprendre et c'est pour ça que je
m'insurge contre ceux qui disent que
vous qui se veut rien dire c'est que ces
gens-là cherchent à masquer cette
distinction qui à mon sens est
fondamentale et justement nous distingue
de l'amérique politiquement
ils y avaient déjà répondu en partie par
l'intermédiaire de vos réponses mais je
vais me faire l'avocat du diable un
petit peu et vous poser une question sur
sur les termes qui sont utilisés par par
la classe dominante pour reprendre des
termes d'inspiration marxiste on a vu
quand même beaucoup ces derniers mois le
terme d' islamo gauchiste mais qui avait
été utilisé à peu près de la même façon
par la classe politico médiatique
aujourd'hui si le walkie sme qui vient
en trombe s'installer dans les discours
est ce que ces termes la classe
dominante elle ne cherche pas à
disqualifier ceux qui remettent en cause
le système politique et économique qui
lui profite en d'autres termes c'est le
plasma cherche t-elle pas maintenir si
privilèges en agitant des étiquettes qui
sont un peu vide de sens mais qui lui
permettent de jeter l'opprobe contre
ceux qui remettent en question le
système capitaliste
merci c'est en effet comme ça je suis
habitué à débattre de manière virulente
avec t
sociologue
français donc de gauche est qui et qui
souvent site en effet l'exemple
moi j'ai pas des expertises de
légitimité particulière à parler d'islam
au gauchisme j'ai cru comprendre que
pierre andré taguieff que je connais
avait
il écrit dans marianne pour dire que le
terme avait été mal utilisé mal compris
parce que c'est lui qui a inventé au
début de l'année 2006
donc j'ai pas lu ses entretiens je ne
prononcerai pas forcément là dessus par
contre ce que je peux dire c'est que il
y a en france
on peut citer par exemple l'exemple de
lieux paix grenoble genre pas j'en parle
souvent dans les entretiens mais parce
que pour moi il est symptomatique on est
quelques mois après la décapitation de
seine elle pâtit et des étudiants dans
ce contexte là qui évidemment présent
dans tous les esprits ça fait la une des
médias à juste titre pendant plusieurs
mois on a des étudiants qui placardent
sur les murs de l'elysée ep grenoble nom
de deux processeurs accusé
d'islamophobie
quand on fait ça en temps c'est ce qu'on
fait en tout cas on assume le risque
pris la police a placé ses deux
étudiants sous protection policière là
on a quoi on a des personnes de gauche
qui traite quelqu'un d'islamophobe dans
un contexte
sulfureux
en fait il faut être sociologue en fait
pour arriver et dire non mais ça ne veut
rien dire est que la monarchie ça me
renvoie à aucune réalité est que comment
on nomme en fait ce phénomène là comment
on oms qui vient d'avoir lieu maintenant
que polémiquer sur le terme qu'est ce
qui logiquement iba rigoureux c'est
vraiment gers et c'est un tropisme
d'élite de dire ça le français qui
voient ça il comprend à quoi ça fait
référence les deux mots d'ailleurs sont
assez bien défini et marc note une
convergence entre les deux camps une
fois pas refaire le débat sur l'islam au
gauchisme je pose juste ça l'a ensuite
dans votre question mais je comprends
bien fait l'avocat du diable peut pas de
soucis milliards ça revient toujours et
ce côté qui est un sophisme parfaite à
qui profite le crime dire qu'on va être
disqualifié l'internât en disant ouais
mais en fait ce terme peut faire le jeu
de en fait c'est pas un argument en
philosophie c'est un sophisme vraiment
et
alors après est ce que est ce que le mot
peut-être mal utilisé est-ce que j'ai
mon arrivée à traiter
zemmour de walk oui évidemment que c'est
dans ce cas dans ce contexte là c'est
mal utilisé ce n'est pas pourtant que
terme ne veut rien dire encore une fois
il a été il a été il est né d'une
revendication positive ce qui n'est pas
le cas en effet des islamo gauchiste
sion volets distincts mais il est amené
les revendications politiques
donc voilà l'argument de la qui profite
le crime n'en est pas un et ce que je
commence à faire maintenant sur les
plateaux c'est commence par poser les
différents sophisme qui arrive
régulièrement et ensuite l'interlocuteur
broc même si en france il n'y a pas tant
que ça il en est l'interlocuteur ou
cuoco compatible si je puis dire
soit il utilise et sophie lis pas ce
qu'il fait souvent et où quelqu'un il
est un peu discréditer parce que dans la
mesure où les saucissons était donné
d'avancé ce qui est démasqué voilà il
nous est il ici n'utilisent pas et
auquel cas souvent ils sont un point et
court d'argument parce que c'est le à
dominer mlle à qui profite le crime le
etc on nous cache les vrais sujets et
que c'est pas les arguments sont certes
pas sur le fond ou manon c'est ce que je
fais parce que à force d'entendre ça
[Musique]
alors j'ai joué une dernière question
pour ma part à vous poser je me suis
intéressé aux nouvelles politiques de
contrôle de contenu et des utilisateurs
pardon et les en place par des gars
femme aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
constamment actualisé
les pressions et le public chez lui les
formes de propagande dans le système
éducatif qui sont mises en place
je voudrais vous demander l'idéologie
boucle incarne-t-elle pas la fin de la
liberté d'expression en tout cas le
danger d'une feinte de liberté
d'expression est ce que le muselage de
l'espace public démocratique voué à la
confrontation des idées comme on le sait
tous ce
n'est pas n'est pas mise en place pour
le transformer cet espace public en
autoroute du consensus
oui vous avez raison par les deux tours
du consensus
moi je pense que déjà beaucoup pavot que
les gars femmes c'est un sujet en soi et
maintenant ce qui est ce qui est
terrible c'est qu'on a une idéologie à
mon sens qu'il ya un vrai potentiel
totalitaires dans la mesure en parler
peut-être mais de qui préempte désaccord
qui explique d'avant ce désaccord des
autres comme étant soit le fruit d'une
naïveté soit le frioul pire d'un cynisme
donc en gros les désaccords désintéressé
sincère loyal
honnête n'est plus possible et qui se
marie avec si vous voulez un potentiel
en tout cas de contrôle social inégalée
dans l'histoire humaine en tout cas à
une telle échelle et la réunion des deux
poserait problème moi je je recommande
vous abonner le notamment le louvre âge
de vivek ram soir à
agen devrait pas être prononcé son nom
de famille qui d'origine indienne qui
s'appelle au wok incorporation ya pas
encore été traduit une équipe unie en
août dernier et lui fait un travail
d'étude sur la mobilisation sur les
dégâts femme très intéressant qui est
effrayant ce qu'il ya des potentiels
vraiment mais proprement hallucinant
cirque eux on se doute qu'ils aient des
manières de de reconnaître on voit par
de la publicité ciblée qui se fait
souvent au sein de conversations
messenger donc messenger vois que vous
avez des messages pour dire at-elle
concerts à l'air sympa vous allez avoir
dans votre mur facebook de publicité
comme ça donc il ya des choses qu on
vous lit d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que
signalé télégramme en un tel succès
notamment avec vos a rappelé aussi qui
était pas clair sur tout ça c'est que
les gens se disent bon j'ai besoin d'eux
il ya une question de sécurité en tout
cas de de vie privée et suffit sur les
combis douille un logiciel existe elle
termes jugés problématiques eh bien on
notera on le fera baisser dans nos
algorithmes ce qui fait la publication
tout cela est possible est concevable
si vous vous laissez ces il suffit
d'appuyer sur le bouton pour que cette
logique démarré il ya déjà des signes de
ça on voit des comptes or pour l'instant
c'est plutôt des comptes à droite mais
ça arrivera aussi à des gens de gauche
républicaine qui saute et ensuite
seulement si il ya une grosse
mobilisation pour dire instagram
facebook twitter réouvrait se comptent
parfois ils cèdent en disant oui on a
fait une erreur c'était une fausse manip
manip et c'est ce qu'ils disent est
généralement et mais c'est terrifiant
c'est à dire que
vous voyez comment cette mécanique peut
se mettre en place on voit par exemple
twitter qui bannit des comptes et ils
l'écrivent pour le sais même pas si les
quelques ce qu'ont constaté qu'ils ne
disent pas twitter banide éconduit qui
met genre comme on dit qui utilisent
quelqu'un par le mauvais genre ce qui
est une offense sur un blasphème ou
connaissait même pas l'existence
aujourd'hui la majorité des français de
là mon sens je pense ça parce que ça
veut dire mais c'est d'ores et déjà à
réprimer par les femmes
j'étais passé chez youtube heures
notamment qui me disaient voilà mon
compte a été supprimé à jamais ce qu'on
appelle un band f parce que j'avais mais
genre est quelqu'un ou alors j'avais des
données mais quelqu'un qui est utilisé
l'ancien pro nom de quelqu'un avant sa
transition donc on voit comment ce qui
était de l'ordre d'un petit délire archi
minoritaire au sein de quelques
militants sur quelques petits réseaux
sociaux devient en quelques années
vraiment on n'a rien de temps sur la
vitesse en soi
modification devrait tous nous inquiéter
devient institué de manière répressive
par les guerres femmes on voit aussi que
linkedin propose là aussi de mettre ces
pros non dans son dans son profil alors
pour l'instant c'est facultatif
peut-être qui après ce sera plus
obligatoire on voit que dans les mails
d'entreprises donc ça c'est pas les gars
femmes mais disons que c'est ce même
tendance sur les pronoms que on
encourage vachement dans le monde anglo
saxon c'est commencent à arriver un peu
en france de mettre ces prenant à la fin
des mails et disons le ce qui arrive et
que ces choses là c'est dans un premier
temps ça fait plus créatifs et ondimba
pour que vous vous opposez chacun de
remettre ses propos et l'étape d'après
ça vient obligatoire il me tient
l'épreuve voulait pas mettre prononcer
mais à chaque fois le à dominer les
latences et le fait si vous êtes content
d'être un méchant réac transforme alors
que lire ma vie même des transgenres
comme caitlin jenner peuvent s'arrêter
transphobes même caroline fourest est
fait reste extrême droite aujourd'hui
l'outil x ray savoir raison garder avec
ces mots là donc on voit ce processus
qui s'emballe qui s'incarne dans les
gars femmes et qui donne un potentiel de
contrôle qui est vraiment énorme et
c'est un sujet dont on ne parle pas
assez est d'ailleurs une des premières
fois qu'on me pose la question je vous
en remercie il faudrait vraiment en
parler beaucoup plus c'est un vrai sujet
il faudrait que le suivait le prochain
président en france quels qu'ils soient
prêts le sujet à bras le corps
alors pour conclure cette entrevue et je
vais vous poser une question qui vaille
est de prendre un petit peu de recul
historique si vous le voulez bien
on parle beaucoup de déconstructivisme
autour de ces questions de walk isme
comme un phénomène nouveau pour
reprendre un anglicisme là quand cette
culture aussi qui aurait pour objectif
de faire table rase de notre histoire et
de nos valeurs occidentales en
particulier mais je me demandais est ce
réellement une idéologie nouvelle par là
je veux prendre du recul historique
comme je le disais puisque on peut
constater que lors de la période de la
révolution française par exemple il y
avait déjà quelques par cette volonté
manifeste d'engendrer une société
nouvelle de construire un homme nouveau
de détruire les grandes figures les
valeurs du temps comme la royauté la
religion catholique la noblesse
autrefois on pouvait voir des églises
qui était brûlé on allait jusqu'à tuer
les dissidents politiques pendant les
périodes de l'histoire
au nom d'une idéologie une nouvelle et
c'est pour ça que ça permet de faire le
lien aussi avec avec l'idéologie go
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
ces faits historiques qui ne permettait
pas de prendre du recul par raport nous
vivons aujourd'hui est de relativiser la
portée la dangerosité l'oenologie mot
contemporaine
oui moi je ne dirais pas relativiser
mais c'est vrai que mettre en parallèle
c'est vraiment pas inintéressant c'est
une très bonne question ne il ya déjà
deux parallèles qu'on peut tracer et
ensuite je rentrerai dans les
divergences
premier parallèle comme vous l'avez bien
souligné ont fait tomber des statuts à
l'époque également il y avait même
radicalité je dirais une même relation à
la pureté à l'utopie qui avait fini par
se retourner contre robespierre on voit
toujours ce même phénomène cercle
n'enclenche un mouvement très radicale
et on passe fatalement d'avant-garde à
rétrograde en très peu de temps la
révolution dévore ses enfants et ses
textes là dessus aucun problème et le
second parallèle d'un point de vue
sémantique
les lumières déjà allé en français on
dit l'élu mais en anglais et en allemand
on dit l'illumination vois ça comme un
mouvement pas de l'obscurité vers la
lumière et le gothisme c'est quoi il ya
ceux qui sont endormis ceux qui sont
éveillés donc il ya là aussi sous les
seins sont de clivage entre eux illuminé
éveillé face à
endormi obscurantistes donc de ce point
de vue là il ya déjà des vrais
parallèles à faire maintenant
d'un point de vue philosophique comme je
l'expliqué tout au long entretien est
vraiment des grands tirages
le rationalisme des lumières qui est
rejeté par la théorie critique de la
race comme je l'avais dit est une
construction sociale blanche le
l'universalisme là aussi il faut être
soit naik soit cynique pour y croire du
point de vue du rookie
mai mais alors là je encore une fois
c'est pas j'emprunte pas dans ma note
tout ça c'est c'est un sujet c'est de
creuser en ce moment sur lequel je
réfléchis vous avez raison de poser la
question une hypothèse c'est qu'on avait
livré dans avant la révolution à voir
les lumières c'est tout un débat
historique sur est ce que les lumières
et la révolution c'est tout à fait la
même chose à ce que la patrie et l'autre
je pose ce débat je mets sur le côté
avant les lumières on avait une
civilisation chrétienne qui globalement
considéré qu'on atteignait l'universel à
travers le particulier donc je suis père
de famille je suis mère de mon petit
village en chef de mon village eux
j'appartiens à ce village est pas tiens
ces deux régions j'appartiens à ce pays
il appartient en tant que chrétiens à
l'universel et au monde et
la république en tout cas les lumières
ou un peu voulu faire l' inverse il met
ses raisonnements à l'envers dire je
suis d'abord l'universel et le
particulier
on l'a vu notamment avec les traitements
des langues régionales était assez
violemment réprimées ce l'histoire de la
république
le particulier est conçu comme un
obstacle à l'universiade celle que on
peut pas être breton et français peut
pas être breton et on va être français
est membre la grande nation des êtres
humains universels et c'est pas
forcément faussaires que si vraiment
vous êtes par exemple l'exemple face il
est breton très vindicatif qui n'aimait
pas la france si votre identité bretonne
se construit contre la france c'est vrai
dans ce cas que le particulier est un
obstacle à l'universel par contre
moi je pense qu'il a pas forcément de
contradictions nées de l'année va vers
l'universel tend vers l'universel et le
problème c'est qu'en en ayant voulu
faire donc je récapitule brièvement
civilisation chrétienne l'universel à
travers le particulier modernité
libérale et lumière la république tous à
l'universel sans le particulier et alors
en conséquence je sais pas mais en tout
cas aujourd'hui que ce que je constate
c'est d'ailleurs ce que déplorent tous
les universaliste aujourd'hui
on a le particulier c en hiver sur
l'universel cirque on tombe dans ce que
veulent les six québécois appellent l'as
l'organisation l'universel que c'est
devenu un slogan et on a un peu du mal à
montrer ces conditions on a des gens qui
ont critiqué la france
qui était à mon sens ce que
l'universalisme d'abord français c'est
là le paradoxe on a durement critiqué la
france qui ensuite tombe des nues en
disant tiens mais c'est bizarre personne
ne croit à l'universel aujourd'hui ça
fait le cas dans tout cas l'universel à
près du pont dans la nuit mais peut-être
que vous avez si vous voulez scier la
branche sur laquelle vous étiez assis
donc il ya un vrai sujet si vous voulez
bon il faudrait creuser et bien merci
beaucoup pierre valentin pour toutes ces
réponses très éclairante sur le
phénomène rock qu'on n'a pas fini
d'entendre je pense dans les médias et
dans dans le monde politique ce sera
peut-être l'un des thèmes centraux de
l'élection présidentielle à venir dans
six mois déjà vous avez publié une étude
je le rappelle sur la fondapol en deux
volumes qui est très éclairante et qui
est source est sérieuse et développé sur
le sujet que je recommande une nouvelle
fois vivement à tous nos auditeurs
je vous laisse le mot de la fin j'espère
que cette entrevue aura donné des
éclaircissements à l'ensemble de nos
auditeurs et n'hésitez pas à retrouver
tout le travail sur notre site copé au
point org et l'ensemble de nos entrevues
politique déjà publiées sur notre chaîne
youtube merci à vous et je vous souhaite
à tous une belle journée
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup à vous
pour votre invitation pour ceux qui
voudraient déjà je vous encourage
vivement à lire les deux notes
puisqu'elles sont gratuitement
disponible sur le site de la fondapol
point org et qu'il faudrait prolonger la
discussion entre exhumé vous prolonger
la question pour peut me suivre sur
twitter
oui peut me suivre sur twitter merci à
vous encore une fois
merci au revoir au revoir